reinkommen gleich mal gute nachrichten
nach der endlosen regierungsbildung
nachdem wir uns monatelang wirklich du
mit uns selbst beschäftigt haben
misch deutschland endlich wieder
international mit die groko rettet die
welt gott sei dank gott sei dank ja wie
schlimm muss das für die anderen länder
gewesen sein
diese vielen wochen ohne deutsche
ratschläge heute war die kanzlerin beim
eu gipfel in brüssel
jean claude juncker voll happy da bist
du ja endlich wieder angela wir wussten
gar nicht was wir machen sollen ohne
deine anweisung und sie so ja ich weiss
ich lass dich nie wieder allein
süß und bei dem gipfel waren natürlich
alle total erleichtert alle europäischen
staatschefs dass trumps strafzölle jetzt
nur die ollen chinesen abkriegen als ich
das ganze debatte betteln bei den amis
doch ausgezahlt aber zwischen paris und
berlin geht es ja um viel mehr das
wissen sie um macros große reform der
eurozone ließen europas steht unter
dauerbeschuss durch populisten süd
europas banken sind immer noch chronisch
pleite
es muss jetzt dringend was passieren
endlich das haben wohl viele heute
gedacht nicht nur weil bundeskanzlerin
merkel mit einer stunde verspätung nach
paris kam
seit einem halben jahr schon wartet
präsident mag
dann jedoch rein mensch steht ja dann
halbes jahr auf der treppe jetzt kann
man mal kurz ideen für europa blöd
finden aber es sind wenigstens ideen und
zwar sehr konkrete ideen aus deutschland
kommt nur heiße luft gucken sie mal den
grow koalitionsvertrag deswegen
schleichen sich in macros reden ja auch
ganz langsam so kleine spitzen richtung
berlin
vor sechs monaten habe ich vorschläge
gemacht die wir miteinander diskutiert
haben
liebe kanzlerin lieber angela sie wissen
wie sehr ich auf unsere gemeinsame
arbeit warten oder auf deutsch schöner
zonen gabi hoffmann hinterher ein
unverschämter ton darf sich eine ewige
kanzlerin natürlich nicht gefallen
lassen
deswegen gab es direkt ein subtiles
franzosen bashing zurück man achte auf
die zwischentöne
wir wollen jetzt gemeinsame wege finden
das ist in der geschichte zwischen
deutschland und frankreich immer dann
von erfolg gekrönt gewesen wenn man auch
ehrlich und hart arbeitet hart arbeiten
der dolmetscher aber völlig überfordert
denn die worte hart arbeiten gibt es im
französischen ja gar nicht
mögliche stille tage in clichy makro
will eine europäische digital behörde
gemeinsame verteidigung einen
eu-finanzminister mit eigenem budget
deutschland antwortet ja vielleicht aber
dann ohne budget also der heißt dann
einfach nur finanzminister als titel als
name könnte buchstäblich jeder machen
oliver welke europäische finanzminister
er hat nichts zu sagen aber er ist sehr
sehr gut
wirklich
ich bin sehr gut wenn ich nichts machen
muss man corp kämpft gegen das
auseinanderdriften europas deutschland
hat immer nur schiss und seine kohle
deswegen sind wir auch so happy dass
jetzt doch keine stahl zöller aus den
usa kommen dank peter altmaier
ja der war anfang der woche auf
friedensmission in washington
ja wirklich ein schlauer move von merkel
ihren knuffig ssten minister hin zu
schicken oder meine jeder liebt altmaier
von beruf wirtschaftsminister aber seine
spezialität sind unlösbare aufgaben
meine spezialität sind gefüllte klöße
den leberwurst gefüllt in einer schinken
rahmsauce auf
man will ja keinen dicken witze über ihn
machen aber erzwingt eine ganz neue
nicht im heute-show fanshop auf die
größe kommt es an
peter altmaier diplomatisches kochbuch
also nochmal vorläufig das ganz wichtig
vorläufig keine zölle auf stahl und
aluminium für die eu wer weiß was uns
das noch kostet wahrscheinlich müssen
wir den amis am ende 23 flugzeugträger
abkaufen und da ist ja auch immer noch
trumps drohung deutsche autos mit zöllen
zu belegen